et à deux règles que tout le monde
connaît n'associe pas quelqu'un qui a
plus à perdre que toi l autre règle ne
fait pas prendre
arrêtez-vous sam
je veux juste pouvoir prendre soin de
toi tu veux que je continue avant de
l'adopter mon petit frère et moi
j'essaie juste de t d c'est notre seule
chance c'est parfait cool que tu sois
revenu les gars âge mais vous confiez 62
mille dollars de mon produit
je le sens bien ce deal
il nous filent poèmes surtout porto
l'écart
deux fois nous tuer
[Musique]
on va vous rendre l'argent c'est juste
qu'on a besoin d'un peu plus de temps à
48 heures
on va tous y aller prendre le pognon et
ce tir et de ce trou on entre et on sort
on sait plus ce qu'est ce qu'on y
connaît notre cage
on entre juste et on sort c'est un hold
up ça rien de sorcier pour le moment
trop ils partagent tout ça il nous reste
encore chacun une sacrée somme secousses
navré de devoir interrompre votre petite
fête ligue open
c'est ta faute c'est toi qui as que
tu peux crever a vécu ou venir avec moi
à toi de voir
je fais ça pour nous
je t'aime bien mec je préfère les api y
est